good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight what a week and it's
only thursday but there's been really
only one story in washington d.c and
across the country there has been an
enormous amount of talk
not just this week but over the last
month about violent extremism
and the people who embrace it the
dangerous people those people are
domestic
terrorists we're told they must be put
down by force the war on terror has
moved stateside extremists have breached
our walls they are inside our country
and in response we must hunt them down
doing that is existential our country
depends on it our lives depend on it
now we're hearing those words non-stop
uncable news but not
just on cable news we're hearing the
very same thing from elected officials
including some republican elected
officials
we're hearing it from the leaders of
federal law enforcement agencies and of
the intelligence agencies
we're hearing it from the pentagon just
this week the new secretary of defense
ordered the entire u.s military
to quote stand down while investigators
cleanse the ranks of political
extremists
and of course we're hearing it from the
business establishment from wall street
and the tech monopolies from the massive
multinational corporations
that increasingly control the contours
of american life
all of them are now on the hunt for
political extremists
and at one level that does not sound bad
because no
sane person is for political extremism
especially violent extremism
we're against it we're for moderation
we're for incremental change
we're for the consent of the governed
we've said that every day for four years
and we meant it we don't like extremists
either we attack them regularly
but it's not enough to be against
something you have to be more precise
than
that what is it that you're against in
order to root out a problem you have to
know what it is
you need a sense of what you're looking
for you need a clear sight picture
you have to define the terms and here's
the remarkable thing
about this public conversation we're
having no one is doing that
have you noticed none of these newly
energized and highly empowered extremist
hunters
have told us exactly what an extremist
is
so we're left to guess we're left to
look around nervously to see if we can
spot one
hoping against hope the whole time
they're not talking about us
are they and if they are what exactly
are they doing
how are they hunting these extremists
they keep telling us about
but will not describe we now know part
of the answer to that question
this show has obtained exclusively
evidence that bank of america
the second largest bank in the country
with more than 60 million customers
is actively but secretly engaged in the
hunt for
extremists in cooperation with the
government
bank of america is without the knowledge
or the consent of its customers
sharing private information with federal
law enforcement agencies
bank of america effectively is acting as
an intelligence
agency but they're not telling you about
it
in the days after the january 6th right
at the capitol bank of america went
through its own customers financial
and transaction records a lot of them
now these were the private records of
americans who
had committed no crime people who as far
as we know had absolutely nothing to do
with what happened at the capitol on
january 6th
but at the request of federal
investigators bank of america searched
its databases looking for people
who fit a specific profile here's what
that profile was and we are quoting
customers confirmed as transacting
either through bank account
debit card or credit card purchases in
washington dc
between january 5th and january 6th
number 2
purchases made for hotels airbnb rsvps
in washington virginia or maryland
after january 6th number three
any purchase of weapons or at a
weapons-related merchant
between january 7th and their upcoming
suspected stay in the dc area around
inauguration day
and four airline related purchases
sixth since january 6th
end quote so what do you notice about
that
profile well the first thing you notice
is that it's
remarkably broad any purchases of
anything in the city of washington dc
any overnight stay anywhere in the
three-state area that spans hundreds of
miles
any purchase not simply of legal
firearms but instead anything bought
from a quote
weapons-related merchant t-shirts
included
and then any airline related purchases
not just flights to washington flights
to anywhere to omaha to thailand
that is a very very wide net an absurdly
wide net
bank of america identified a total of
211 customers who met these quote
thresholds of interest and it was at
that point the show has learned
bank of america turned over the results
of its internal scan
to federal authorities apparently
without notifying the customers who were
being spied upon
federal investigators then interviewed
at least one of these unsuspecting
people
and that person we've learned hadn't
done anything wrong and in the end
was cleared imagine if you were that
person
the fbi hauls you in for questioning in
a terror investigation
not because you've done anything
suspicious you haven't you bought plane
tickets and visited your country's
capital you thought you could do that
you thought it was your country now
they're sweating you because your bank
which you trust with your most private
information information of everything
you buy
has ratted you out to the feds without
telling you
without your knowledge because
bank of america did that you are being
treated like a member
of al qaeda what country is this
it doesn't matter how much you despise
donald trump
or how much you believe that hatred of
trump justifies suspending
this country's ancient civil liberties
going through that experience would
scare the hell out of you
absolutely a terror suspect you would
think
does anyone else know about this is
there a record of this interview why i
lose my job because of it
that actually happened to someone it's
hard to believe it but it did
we asked bank of america about this they
confirmed it actually happened by not
denying it
here is their statement in full which
manages to make the whole thing even
creepier assuming that's possible
quote we don't comment on our
communications with law enforcement
well apparently not all banks it
continues have responsibilities under
federal law
to cooperate with law enforcement
inquiries in full compliance with the
law
end quote now the last part
from a lawyer's perspective is the
essence in full compliance with the law
it's the law we had no choice but that's
not true
bank of america did have a choice the
bank could have resisted turning over
information on its innocent customers to
federal investigators but bank of
america did not do that
nor is it clear if we're going to be
precise about it that what bank of
america did
is even legal it turns out it's not
simple
it's a gray area we spoke to a number of
lawyers about this today
some of them told us that what bank of
america did might in fact
not be legal and could in fact be
challenged in court
one knowledgeable attorney pointed us to
12 usc 3403
that's a federal law that allows banks
to tip off the feds to any information
that quote
may be relevant to a possible violation
of any statute or regulation
now the doj instructs federal agents to
remind the banks of that law and of
course they do with maximum aggression
but the question is legally what
constitutes information that may be
relevant to a possible crime buying a
muffin
in washington dc on january 5th does
that make you a potential domestic
extremist
according to bank of america yes yes it
does
this is the moment when for the sake of
our country and our grandchildren who
will live here
we need to pause and breathe deeply
searching for wisdom avoiding hysteria
and ask what are the rules
what for god's sakes is a political
extremist
a lot hangs on that question maybe
everything
please tell us but they won't tell us
pointedly
they won't tell us today at the white
house for example the new national
security adviser jake sullivan
told reporters that domestic extremism
is the urgent crisis
of our time rooting out domestic
political extremism is more important
than anything else more important than
getting a job
running your business tending to your
family but sullivan did not again
tellingly explain what it is
so build back better isn't just about
economics it's about national security
as well
and then it's about the set of issues
that working families in this country
are facing every day that are
challenging their lives and livelihoods
the pandemic
climate change the threat of domestic
violent extremism
domestic violent extremism there it is
the worst thing
but no sense of what that means
we're starting to believe they're not
defining it for a reason
what's the other explanation yesterday
an op-ed in the new york times asked
this question
are private messaging apps the next
engine gaps signal
a bunch of others they're encrypted no
one can read it the new york times
doesn't like this
why because if they can't see what
you're saying maybe you shouldn't be
allowed to say it
as the newspaper put it quote the shift
to private messaging has renewed a
debate over whether encryption is a
double-edged sword
while the technology prevents people
from being spied upon
it might also make it easier for
criminals and misinformation spreaders
to do harm without getting caught notice
are in the same sentence
they're pretty much the same thing
what's a misinformation spreader what's
someone who doesn't agree with the new
york times
obviously a violent extremist and
they're dangerous
if you think we're joking we're not
they're pulling this thread every day
according to democratic party we need to
start screening the social media
accounts
of people who work for the government
just to make sure
so it's time for us to open our eyes
and recognize what's going on the fact
that we do not
look at social media of potential
recruits into the military
flabbergast me